finish them finish them Hamas did this
you know Iran's behind it finish them uh
Tucker Carlson who of course is no
longer with Fox and he's doing the show
on X formerly Twitter I suppose uh he
was very critical of Nikki Haley on some
of her comments responding to these
attacks so there's a lot at stake in how
we encourage Israel to respond to the
horrifying Hamas attacks wisdom and
long-term thinking are essential but you
will not be surprised to learn that is
not what we are getting why watch this
person for example who happens to be the
media's pick for president of the United
States this is not just an attack on
Israel this is an attack on America
because they hate us just as much and
what we have to understand is this is
the reason that we have to unite around
making sure our enemies do not hurt our
friends America can never be so arrogant
to think we don't need friends just like
we needed them on 9/11 that's why
Ukraine needs us when Russia's doing
this that's why Israel needs us when
Hamas and Iran are doing this and I'll
say this to to prime minister Netanyahu
finish them finish them Hamas did this
you know Iran's behind it finish them
they should have hell to pay for what
they've just done this was an attack on
America she says when in fact it was not
and for that reason we must quote finish
Iran a nation of nearly 90 million
people what are we watching here this is
not sober leadership she's a child and
this is the Tantrum of a child ignorant
Cocker bloodthirsty yet no one in
Washington scolded her for it in fact
they aped her
hysteria I have to say and it slightly
pains me to say this I'm really
disappointed in Tucker right now and and
Ben that guy that we mentioned before
over ear Network he really went off on
Tucker and I shared it I think it was
right look I I'm with you Michael
especially on this one the Ukraine thing
it makes no sense we have poured money
and and it's just insane there this is a
completely different situation but
Tucker said a couple things there that
make no sense to me first off I have
never heard anyone anyone say that Nikki
Haley is the darling of the media I mean
just I've never heard anyone say that
period uh and secondly this wasn't an
attack on America except how many
Americans were killed I think at least
11 and I think they have 22 American
hostages right now which as far as I
know we haven't even demanded back I
mean if you kill 11 Americans is that
not an attack on America at the very
least that doesn't mean we just go in
and bomb the place to high hell but I
think he's playing a bit of a licus game
Here Andrew what do you think yeah no
there's no question about it first of
all you could tell from what Nikki Ali
was saying that she wasn't saying finish
Iran she was saying finish AAS who was
backed by Iran so he willfully
misunderstood her uh you know the
opposite of Neo conservativism this idea
that we should fight every war
everywhere is isolationism and both of
those are childish and the evidence that
Tucker Carlson has subscribed to the
childishness of isolationism is that his
argument against going into to Ukraine
was that Putin really wasn't as bad a
guy as we thought he was and he wasn't
really our enemy that's the one argument
you can't make for not going into
Ukraine you can make all kinds of
arguments all kinds of good reasons to
stay out of Ukraine or limit the amount
of support we give to Ukraine or be
careful about Ukraine all kinds of
arguments the fact that Putin is a
sweetheart is not one of them the man is
a gangster he is a genuine enemy of this
country as well as anybody decent
anywhere and he kills you know people
who disagree with him even if they live
in other countries we have to oppose him
but how much is a fair question the same
thing is true here yes of course an
attack on Israel is not an attack on
America sometimes Israel's uh interests
and America's interests diverge but an
attack on our best ally in the Middle
East is a moment for reflection and
consideration of what we should do we
don't have any other friends any real
friends in the Middle East except for
Israel and it is an important wedge that
we have gotten into a very very troubled
area uh from which a lot of War uh tends
to come so
I just thought Tucker that was just bad
reasoning it was drum beating and it was
uh basically uh trying to stir up the
America First crowd I I really was not
uh thrilled with it at all yeah and I
think I can speak for all of us but
correct me if I'm wrong like we all like
Tucker I I've played clips of him all
the time I think he's right on like 95%
of the
stuff